it's been described as the biggest ever
expose of financial secrets and appears
to implicate presidents prime ministers
and billionaires the leaked files have
been dubbed the pandora papers our
international affairs editor dominic
baghorn is here with more details
dominic
we are used to seeing the super rich
hiding their money away offshore it's
the kind of prerogative of the super
rich you might like to say and uh for a
long time time they've been able to get
away with it without being snooped on
and then we've seen sort of one
investigation after another looking at
what they've been doing but they all the
investigations so far have been based on
leaks from one company
this is based on leaks from 14 companies
and it's a huge net they've cast and
it's it's thrown up some very
interesting facts we've got if we look
at this sort of summary of what the
pandora papers uh has been looking at
nearly 12 million
11.9 million files have been leaked to
the investigators uncovering the hidden
assets of 35 current and former world
leaders and more than 300 politicians
and officials and some celebrities in
there as well we understand and the
documents coming from 14 offshore
service providers so those are people
working for those offshore service
providers leaking information to these
investigators um and you might think
that we're talking about caribbean tax
havens or classic offshore haven is that
caribou the cayman islands if you like
but uh one place that seems to be coming
up again and again in this investigation
is much closer to home it's london and
despite all the controversy about london
being somewhere where ill-gotten gains
are parked it remains the place
according to pete jones from
one of the groups investigating this the
organized crime and corruption reporting
project london remains a big problem at
the heart of this
i think it should be worrying that
regulators
law enforcement are struggling to track
down the people who are behind these
kinds of schemes because they're hidden
by the secrecy offered by some of these
tax havens it doesn't really seem to be
the political will to track down this
dirty money and instead you know it
leaves places like london as a kind of
open uh welcoming venue for that kind of
dirty money and any dirty money
compromises the integrity of any economy
now you might be wondering who's been
singled out for various legal reasons we
can't name too many names but one of
them is the czech prime minister andres
babis uh who's accused in these
investigations of acquiring a 12 million
dollar chateau in france on the french
riviera with two swimming pools and a
cinema and
he's come out fighting tonight on
twitter
rejecting the allegations saying the
following i have never done anything
illegal or wrong but that does not
prevent them from trying to denigrate me
again and influence the czech
parliamentary election so he is
defending himself i think in the days
ahead we're going to see more and more
names uh being brought out into the open
kings uh politicians dictators public
officials all accused of being involved
in using offshore
havens not necessarily illegally but not
within the spirit of the law and
certainly taking recourse to the kind of
methods that we as ordinary people can't
use to try and make the most of our
money an ongoing story that we'll keep
across dominic thank you